was geht hier vor marks und herzlich
willkommen zum heutigen video heute habe
ich wieder meine sache am start die
wirklich nicht 08 15 ist und zwar habe
ich ein tool gefunden bzw eine website
die tatsächlich so kommen in deiner
umgebung anzeigt wie es fragt man sich
warum braucht man das einerseits
brauchen wir das war das in der nähe
feature von pokémon in letzter zeit
einfach nicht funktioniert es gibt er
den free steps klitschko einfach nur
drei fußstapfen angezeigt werden egal
wie nato beim pokémon bist und dadurch
ist es quasi unmöglich dass man pokémon
findet die wirklich in der umgebung sind
andererseits ist es total hilfreich
werden heute schon total weit gekommen
bist aber einfach ein pokémon partout
nicht findet so ich zeige euch jetzt mal
wie das geht
also hier seht ihr die oberfläche das
geht sowohl mobil als auch am computer
ich zeig euch erstmal vom computer die
default location hier ist jetzt der
santa monica beach man kann das alle 30
sekunden aktualisieren und hier oben hat
jede x-beliebige location eingeben und
jetzt guckt euch das mal an die namen
von den pokémon sind halt auf englisch
weil klar ist eine englische plattform
hier haben wir zum beispiel eine pumpe
luft ein pikachu ein mirakel ein capa
d'or seht ihr also hier zb cappuccio
dieses programm habe ich nicht ein
einziges mal gesehen in meiner pokémon
go spielzeit nicht einmal das ist wie
heißt dann auch rhi zu ross ist das
glaube ich ja aber generell kann man
sagen dass man mit diesem ding echt
pokémon findet die man sonst nicht
finden würde und ich finde das super
hilfreich ist ist so ein bisschen wie
soll man sagen es ist nicht so 100
prozent clean aber zumindest in der zeit
wo dieser trees tabs klitsch nicht
funktioniert kann man das finde ich
guten gewissens verwenden und damit ihr
nicht denkt der typ erzählt einfach nur
und das kann doch jeder hier irgendwie
so ein ding animieren wo ein paar
pokémon drauf sind ich habe das ganze
tatsächlich ausprobiert und bin nur für
dieses video mit meinem bruder in die
stadt gefahren so leute wir haben hier
gerade 2001 schubert auf der karte
und diesmal auch das ganze so so stimmt
wurde im alter über lok modul ja leider
dazu war vom leben nebo lag hier vorne
von jörg butt ist nehme ich mir
natürlich mal mit leuten zum nebula
gesagt man ja nicht nein da gucken
übernehmen jetzt muss ich das x
abgleichen einen super und zweitens
waren wir vorne an der an der ecke so da
schauen wir doch super
fahren wir weiter geradeaus wie das hat
sie das hat auf jeden fall schon mal
gestimmt
das sind schon zwei weitere topsoft der
karte so kann ich zu fuß weitergehen
halten
wir gehen zu fuß weiter und müssen
gucken ob die die karte noch aktuell ist
ihr seht ihr gerade auf dem iphone dass
das ding irgendwie ein bisschen probleme
hat und am laden ist erläuterte sagt man
dass man in stuttgart gehen sodass wir
haben jetzt hier das super anstatt dass
wir gerade auf der karte gesehen hatte
und weil an ihm jetzt eine chemie wäre
okay ist ein super eigentlich will dass
kein mensch aber nur kleine
demonstration was mir schmeckt und fuß
laufen draußen super einfach da kommen
schon region ich verwerfe hat meine
ganze tabelle für dieses tracks
normalerweise würde ich für geld kein
super tag
dort trennt leute also das der beweis
das funktioniert tatsächlich alter gibt
dir das wie hoch und
digger wp drei fragezeichen auf meinem
level ich bin level 21 das heißt das hat
irgendwie 1500 euro sonst auf das wird
mit abstand mein stärkstes gucken und
sagen falls auf der chemie bärige
wallert und es wird rot sein oder
crocosmia orange großartige chance
einmal zweimal war es direkt remis blieb
ruhig und rentner seien so okay leute
wird im block registriert ich habe noch
nie intent asche aus einem ei bekommen
1987 direkt an die eltern ist es direkt
mein stärkstes stärkstes trocken direkt
die nämlich dramatisch dass ich
mitgenommen heute gut drauf so leute und
die beiden die ich gerade eben gefangen
habe werden auch hier angezeigt auf dem
latent oxer und romano die beiden
deswegen hier angezeigt ich habe sie
gerade schon gefangen also mit anderen
worten man kann definitiv bestätigen das
ding funktioniert und ich habe einfach
mein stärkstes pokémon gefangen alter
was ist das also auf jeden fall sehr zu
empfehlen falls sie irgendwie in der
stadt unterwegs sind oder sie schauen
wollte ok wo muss ich hingehen dass ich
ein pokémon findet welches ich noch
nicht habe gleich so leute hier bin ich
noch mal generell kann man wirklich
sagen das ding ist super praktisch für
die leute die wirklich besessen sind ihr
pokédex voll zu bekommen aber auch für
die leute die irgendwie sehen in meiner
nähe ist nie doping ich musste ihn
finden aber der in der nähe back
funktioniert nicht nachrücken halt
schnell bei poco wissen rein und sieht
okay in die doping ist in die richtung
läuft dahin fängt das ding und so
funktioniert das ich hoffe ihr könnt
vielleicht was anfangen mit der homepage
und ja das war's dann vom nächsten
pokémon go video wenn es euch gefallen
hat lass mal ein leichter und ein abo
falls ihr bock drauf habt müsst ihr
natürlich nicht und bis zum nächsten